bonjour vous avez gling oui tenez
regardez comme c'est joli c'est une
pochette comme attentes adélaïde m'a
envoyé pour mon anniversaire c'est
mignon n'est ce pas il y à même à ma
tête brody dessus
c'est très beau seulement le problème
c'est que je ne sais pas quoi mettre
dedans
aujourd'hui joue comme il est beau mon
canari roses aux pieds et dix membres a
cité ces résumés oui bonjour
mademoiselle tout est bon qu est-ce que
vous avez l'art autour du cou ça ouais
c'est un médaillon qui m'a offert ma
grand mère oui y'a quoi ça sert ça ne
sert à rien de kazimiya c'est un bijou
alors les bijoux ça ne sert à rien ça
sert à décorer à faire joli ah oui je me
souviens maintenant julie me l'avait
déjà dit louis - casino celui ci a un
secret j'adore les sauts cry surtout
quand on les dit au creux de l'oreille
un garde regarde il s'ouvre à oui très
bien et qu'est ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur
là ce sont les cheveux de mon grand père
le mari de ma grande points alors je ne
comprends pas pourquoi est ce que votre
grand mère météo autour de son cou les
cheveux de son mari sa maman mais c'est
une coutume d'autrefois casimir autres
fins ont porté autour de son cou les
cheveux de quelqu'un qu'on aimait
beaucoup dans un médaillon ah bon
voilà qu'est ce qui te préoccupe casimir
et bien moi je n'ai pas de cheveux dont
personne ne peut m'aimait beaucoup
et comme je n'ai pas non plus de dents
je ne pourrais même pas en donner une en
souvenir au mont la paix
je lui ai même pas l'oreille ainsi c'est
bien simple sûrement demande une je ne
pourrais même pas la donne est
vraiment personne ne peut mais mais
beaucoup moins on est six minutes aimons
tous beaucoup casimir et puis on peut
très bien remplacer les cheveux par des
photos bon ben il nous en avons tous
beaucoup ici n'est ce pas les enfants et
moi bien sûr ça va alors eh bien pour te
consoler bien j'ai une grande nouvelle
attaque est laquelle laquelle
j'organise ce soir une grande surprise
par ces écoutes où les amis l'île aux
enfants terribles a très bien et bien
sûr tu es invité mais tu n'oublies pas
d'amener son cousin hippolyte je veux
bien mais vous savez il danse comme un
fer à repasser
la casimir tu est très méchant non c'est
la vérité je la mènerai quand même mais
vous pouvez préparer une trousse à
pharmacie pour les pieds écrasés
tazi millions coûte bon je vous attends
soyez à l'heure je vais tout préparé à
tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure
casimir casimir à vic il faut que tu me
rendent un service 1 et 15 passes 1
c'est un cadeau que toi seul peut me
faire si tu es vraiment mon cousin goyer
et alors qu'est ce que ça mais pourquoi
tu dis toujours qu'est ce que c'est
parce que je pense à comment tu penses
quand je te parle mais comment est-ce
possible 5 hippolyte tu as encore plus
bête que je ne pensais tu crois or je
n'ai pas j'en suis maintenant certains
alors que voulais tu me demandez
pas je ne sais plus un jeune fille alors
non seulement tu es bec mais en plus tu
n'as pas de mémoire à tous étaient là
c'était c'était
sa gelée sur le bout de la langue il
invita les casimir russes n'ont pas de
langue à tous ce qu'est
athée je me souviens casimir il faut que
tu m'as apprennent à danser ouais enfin
qu est complètement fou armé casimiri
coûte il faut il faut à tout prix que
tout le monde nous admirent ce soir non
non il n'en est pas question
casimir pour que l'on m'a demi à moi
c'est tout mais casimir si je ne danse
pas tout le monde dira que les casimir
us ne savent pas blessé
l'alarmé police mais je crois que pour
une fois tu as raison tu vois bien alors
bon je veux bien mais à une seule
condition y aura 10 j'aimerais que tu
veux ouais ouais son rêve j'aime bien
dans la bonne écoute alors commençons
tout de suite à leçon de danse ausy par
ici pour le toit comme ça d'abord le
menu est comme ça
un de
ouakam 1 2 ouattara
2 3 4 et casser les bras voilà on tourne
où
es-tu
[Musique]
attention on se croise
20 30 ou un bras tarte et révérence en
souplesse
bon c'est pas trop mal pour un début
alors maintenant autre chose voilà la
somme a oui je me souviendrai
[Musique]
enfin
mais très élégant de ce soir
et vous
où que la nouveau tous les deux auront
mais quelle distinction
mademoiselle voulez vous m'accordez
cette danse née volontiers monsieur
alors dans son dance hall ibra
[Musique]
mais tu danses très bientôt
en 2000 je suis rouge de confusion
[Musique]
mais que fait-on hippolyte dans le doute
que julie elle est devenu complètement
fou mais voilà décapité julie et
casimir europe qui publie
ces
machins julien votre ravissant de
coiffure vous avez un grand trou sans
cheveux derrière la tête or il peut
n'étant pas toi mais c'est pas moi c'est
casimir
mais que se passe-t-il
si jamais il apparaît dans le sac voilà
les chemins que je voulais
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
mais casimir mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont à
faire est douce et cela enfin enfin
c'est cette unité devant le mazel [ __ ]
c'est même pas une idée de nuit à noter
toi toi c'est pour mettre dans mon petit
médaillon socrates
s'est engagé ce parti mais je ne veux
absolument rien gâcher du tout je veux
simplement mettre les saveurs de tous
mes amis dans mon médaillon voilà je ne
veux rien gâcher c'est une bonne
surprise noir
[Musique]
à
delphi et sans lien est ce que vous êtes
déjà un lit dans un zoo oui oui alors
savez vous que le soir dans les eaux les
animaux rêve et savez-vous de coin il
rêve
non alors écoutez cette poésie de michel
butor
attention qu'on commence
à la tombée de la nuit quand se sont
refermées l'écrit
l'éléphant rêve à son grand troupeau le
rhinocéros à des troncs d'arbres
je ne comprends pas ce qui peut
tellement plaire aux rhinocéros dans les
troncs d'arbres enfin passons il rêve à
ce qu'ils veulent un ils sont libres
alors l'hippopotame rêve adelac clair la
girafe à des frondaisons de fougères le
dromadaire
ils reviendront madère tu cet animal
kaeppelin de bronze partout à des oasis
tintin le bison à des océans d'air
dissociant dire ça c'est sûrement très
beau que tu te rends compte une prairie
verte et grandes qui ressemble à un
océan mais as tu sais des animaux il
répond si le lion est bien le lion rêve
ras des craquements dans les feuilles le
tigre de sibérie a des traces sur la
neige
l'ours polaire à des cascades
poissonneuse parce qu'il aime bien
poisson l'ours polaire un tel film la
panthère à des plages passant dans le
rayon de lune le gorille qui aiment les
bananes rêve à des bananiers croulants
de leurs fleurs violettes les fleurs des
bananiers sont violés je ne savais pas à
des coups de vent dans des camions de
nuages le phoque à des archipels
mouvants de la banquise disloqué et les
enfants du gardien quoi ils rêvent sonia
il vient moi je suis persuadé que les
enfants du gardien et tous les autres
enfants eh bien ils doivent tous rêvé de
l'île aux enfants
excusez moi vous êtes encore là je
croyais que vous étiez déjà partis au
revoir passé une bonne nuit